okay today I'm going to talk to you
about the blood we're going to talk
about the main four components of the
blood and what their kind of role is in
each case so first of all we have red
blood cells now the scientific name for
red blood cells that we might come
across is a reef through sites but
basically that just means red blood
cells now the job of red blood cells is
absolutely essential because what they
do is they carry oxygen around the body
now we need this oxygen for respiration
okay so red blood cells they kind of
have this shape here a shape that's
referred to as a biconcave disc they
also have no nucleus now the reason why
they have this particular shape and no
nucleus it's so they can carry as much
oxygen as possible this gives them a
very large surface area in order to
carry as much oxygen as possible so the
way that oxygen attaches to it is the
red blood cells actually contain this
thing called hemoglobin now hemoglobin
is just this red pigment and the oxygen
actually binds to the hemoglobin it
attaches to it when it attached the
hemoglobin we form this thing called oxy
hemoglobin so the whole purpose of a red
blood cell is to carry oxygen around the
body and to deliver it to every cell for
the process of aerobic respiration okay
next up we have white blood cells now
these also have a very important job
what these do is they fight against
pathogens
now pathogens these are just
microorganisms so tiny living things
that can make us ill give us a disease
so there's two types of white blood
cells we need to know about and that
those are phagocytes
number two is lymphocytes okay so focus
i'ts
what they do is they surround a named
Gulf or pathogen so for pathogen let's
say there's one there gets into our body
the phagocyte can actually kind of
surround it and engulf it break it down
so that is one way that it can that can
affect the white blood cells can fight
against pathogens phagocytes engulf them
using the process of phagocytosis now
the other way that white blood cells can
fight against pathogens he's in
lymphocytes so let's say this is a
pathogen that enters the body right here
so this is the microorganism that makes
you well what lymphocytes can do is they
release these things called antibodies
and these antibodies can kind of attach
to the pathogen and help to break them
down so we've got the two different
types of white blood cells phagocytes
that engulf and lymphocytes that release
antibodies okay next up we have these
little things called platelets that
travel round in the blood
so what platelets are is there are
little fragments of cells that have no
nucleus not much at all they're just
parts of cell fragments themself that
can help to to clot the blood so they're
involved in blood clots now these are
really important let's say this is a
blood vessel here and unfortunately
we've hurt ourselves and we've got a
kind of cut in this vessel here okay now
obviously we'd be losing blood right
here now what the platelets do is they
kind of clump together and they form a
clot now this means first of all this
means there's no further blood loss so
it reduces blood loss because no blood
can now exit through here secondly it
means that pathogens remember those
microorganisms that make
give us a disease those pathogens cannot
get in anymore
so therefore the platelets have served
their purpose by forming that clot
finally we need to know about the plasma
so what the plasma is is it's a straw
colored liquid and this is the stuff
that just carries everything along this
is the liquid that carries all of these
useful things along now I've actually
come up with this thing here called warp
punch that's hopefully gonna help us
remember the different things that get
carried in the plasma so this is all of
the different stuff that gets carried
along in the blood so we've got white
blood cells remember which fight against
pathogens we have antibodies released by
white blood cells we have red blood
cells that are carrying the oxygen along
for us we also have our platelets so
those are the things we've learned about
so far however there's more stuff in the
blood as well it also carries along
proteins there will also be your reer
which is a waste product produced so
from the liver to the kidneys we will
have nutrients carried along in the
blood we will also have carbon dioxide
because this is a waste product from
respiration so we want to take this to
the lungs to get rid of it and we'll
also have hormones so hormones are
chemical messengers that travel in the
blood so if you can remember warp punch
you should hopefully remember all of the
different things that contain in the
blood thank you very much